Er spricht Willkommen zum Podcast-Tuefo. Ihr Gastgeber sind Florentin Wiew und Stefan Titz. Präsentieren von Worst-Bird-Produktion. Krara! Krara! So kommentieren alle Okay, wir fahren doch nach Italien.
So kommentieren alle anderen Länder Fussball unerträglich in meinen Ohren.
Es ist Le Podcast Uffe, Le Podcast Uffe de Podcast, Le Podcast avec Furentiville et Stéphane Dizel.
Obwohl in Frankreich hat man ja ganz wenige Anglizismen, das heißt, vielleicht heißt der Podcast dort anders. Nämlich? Le Pod. A-Avret. Die fliegende Stimme. Le Voiseau. Le Voiseau. Der Stimmenvogel. Vielleicht, ich weiss es nicht genau. Ja. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Wo ich mir sicher bin, ist, dass Dolce-Hann-Football, stimmt, kann sein, wenn die Folge rauskommt, sind wir entweder gegen Spanien ausgeschieden oder eben nicht. Ich drücke dir Deutschland und Nationalmannschaft die Daumen, ich bin richtig im EM-Fieber Florentin. Aber vielleicht schon, also vielleicht, das ist natürlich jetzt sehr bitter für unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer, die jetzt gerade vor dem zersplitterten Scherbenhaufen ihrer Hoffnung sitzen und du ihnen, ja also der spielt so toll, ja also der Klienzmann, was der wieder macht, also die sind so toll, ich mag die ganze Mannschaft so gern, und jeder von denen hat ein Eigentor geschossen am Samstag, jeder von denen schiesst ein Eigentor und die armen Leute da draußen müssen das jetzt hören, wir verlieren 11-0, alle schießen ein Eigentor und ich mag immer noch alle, ich mag immer noch alle einzigen so gern. Wie viele Eigentore müsste jeder einzelne Spieler schießen, bis du das Vertrauen verlierst? Die Menge an Eigentoren ist nicht gegen meine Liebe, gegenüber aller Spieler. Wirklich, auch wenn wir 77-0, jeder schießt sieben Eigentor. Ich hab die alle so gern, aber auch von anderen Teams. Aber ich möchte alle, weil alle geben da draußen ihr Bestes. Und ich möchte gerne jeden Spieler nehmen und so auf die Stirn küssen. Okay. So einfach nehmen. Während des Spiels auch mit Schweiss im Spiele? Ja, das Opfer würde ich durchaus bringen, aber ich möchte jedem Spieler so den Kopf nehmen, das hat ja auch was Beruhigendes. Und du bist ja auch grösser als alle Spieler, das heißt du kannst dir ja so zutun, tätscheln einfach. Ja, wenn so ein grosser Typ kommt und ihn mal alle in den Arm nimmt, ich glaube, es hat was sehr Beruhigendes.
Oder so Engelchen, Engelchen, Flieg vielleicht könntest du ja machen, damit die sich freuen nach dem Spiel.
Ne, was ich, aber ich finde, das hat mein Alter was sehr so Elternhaftes, dieses Tätscheln auf dem Kopf.
Und dann, das macht ja auch Partner, Partnerin macht das ja nicht, selten vielleicht.
Viel zu selten, viel zu selten, leider. Aber sowas ja, leider, leider, ja, ja, das ist sehr gut, da können wir gleich nochmal in Ruhe drüber sprechen. Und deswegen möchte ich jedem einfach so einen Kuss auf die Stieren geben. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich bin auch im Fussballfieber, ich habe sogar Fussball gespielt. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt unter den UEFA-Regeln der Herren, ob das wirklich stimmt. Aber für Aber ... Für die, die es nicht wissen, die UEFA Euro 2024 der Herren, der Herren A-Mannschaften. Richtig. Und deswegen war ich natürlich auch in Fussballspielung, aber nicht nur ich tatsächlich, viele andere sind auch in Fussballspielung in diesem Lande, vor allem Kinder. Ja. Und die sind im Park unterwegs und treten das Leder hin und her. Hin und her, Bis ihnen ganz schummrig wird. Richtig, genau. Bis ihnen die Hoffnung, selbst einmal Fussballstar zu sein, den Kopf komplett durchgequirlt hat und leider keiner mehr Bankkaufmann sein will, was noch ein großes Problem sein wird. Problem. Und deswegen, es war wirklich wie die Szene wie im Film, wie ich eigentlich, ich hätte eine andere Vorgeschichte gebraucht. Ich hätte, glaube ich, für diesen Moment ein ganz anderes Leben gebraucht. Da habe ich bis dahin falsch gelebt. Ich glaube, das richtige Leben wäre gewesen, ich wollte früher Fussballstar werden, dann hatte ich aber das Spiel, wo ich leider elf Eigentore geschossen habe. Ja, oder so den Meniskus zerrt. Genau, Meniskus ist mir aufs Bein gefallen und dann habe ich mir leider den Knöchel geprellt und jetzt habe ich so einen mittelgut laufenden Podcast und Trauer und Sturf immer so, aber denke eigentlich immer noch danach. Und dann bin ich im Park tatsächlich unterwegs und dann tatsächlich Junge spielt da mit seinem Vater Fussball hin und her, der Junge tritt den Ball. Er rollt in deine Richtung. Kommt natürlich nicht in meinem Ansatz dem Tor nahe, also ein Winkel, der fast die Geometrie schon Lügen straft, also wie diese Amateure es immer schaffen. Und dann hast du gesagt, ah, versuch's lieber gar nicht. Also wirklich, der komplett im 230 Grad Winkel von der gewünschten Richtung weg und dann rollt der Ball direkt auf mich zu. Es ist wirklich, das Universum ist ein ein kruder scherz ja dass leute wie wir dann immer die die pille wie ich nenne von den füssen wie ich nenne bekommen ist ja völlig absurd weil das ist ja gefühlt immer auf uns nicht auf die skilled leute darauf warten sondern wir die denken bitte nicht auf mich bitte nicht auf mich bitte nicht auf mich und dann genau vor die füße ja und ich bin auch jemand ich glaube glaube, ich bin sehr aufmerksam, was meine Umgebung betrifft, gerade weil ich sehr vorsichtig bin. Aber zum Beispiel so Sachen wie, da kommt ein alter Klassenkamerad die Straße mir entgegen. Das sehe ich auf 500 Metern, aber sieht man mir nicht an. Ich glaube, würde man mich mit einer verkrisselten Überwachungskamera sehen, man würde mir nicht anmerken, dass gerade mein Gymnasiastenschwarm 500 Meter entgegen ist. Währenddessen der Check mit Gucken rein, er guckt ihn an, Panik, dreht sich im Kreis, weil er nicht weiss, wohin er ausweichen soll, er hat keine Lust zu sprechen offensichtlich, fasst an sich alles an, macht so weirde Bewegungen wie schlechte Schauspieler, so guckt neunmal auf die Uhr, er tippt mit dem Finger auf die Uhr, wie viel Uhr ist es denn? Er hat keine Smartwatch an, aber gut, er hat nicht mehr eine Uhr an, aber er tippt auf die Uhr, läuft rum, seit dem Kreis, dann beschleunigt er den Schritt in die falsche Richtung, dreht um, rennt weg und verkriecht sich in die Mülltonne. Stolpert über den Bordstein und flieht in die Mülltonne. Und deswegen habe ich das schon relativ früh gesehen, den Ball in meine Richtung. Ich kann das ja ganz gut mit so Winkeln abschätzen und so. Hast du gerade gesagt, es war 130, kam für das Episode geschlossen. Dann überlegt man sich natürlich, wie früh steigt man da jetzt schon ein in den Blickkontakt mit dem Gegner auch, wie macht man das jetzt?
Gegner sind wir jetzt schon, okay. Weil natürlich so, ich dachte mir, einerseits müsste man jetzt so einen richtigen Freistoß machen, wo man wirklich so auf vier Schritte Anlauf nimmt und dann voll ballert, aber ich dachte mir, nee, ich entdecke den lieber im letzten Moment und das ist dann eher so ein, oh wow, wie schnell kann der reagieren. Ich habe mir überlegt, welche Art von Idealfussballer möchte ich sein. Will ich der sein, der richtig mit irgendwie 280 kmh die Pille ins Leder wemesselt, oder bin ich eher der No-Look, eher so ein Fring. Ja, genau, eher so ein Lieblich. Du wolltest sagen, eher wie der Frings. Ja, wie so ein ... Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt massgeblich seine Spielercharakteristika zusammenfasst, aber okay, ich verstehe, was du meinst. Naja, oder früher, bevor er auf der Bildfläche des deutschen Sports erschienen ist, durchaus, und so habe ich den Ball in letzter Moment angenommen und die Pille, ja, obwohl Pille in der Regel nicht kugelförmig sind, es sei denn, es sind Globuli, und da würde ich mal gerne überdenken, was du für Medikamente trotst. Okay, streich mirepille, wir sagen das Runde. Ja, und das Kugelige, die Kugel, der Ball. Und dann habe ich ihn tatsächlich relativ gut zurückgepasst und muss sagen, ich habe ein extremes Talent für Fußball. Ich bin gut im Passen, deswegen glaube ich, falls die UEFA24, der Herrn 11, der Herrn, jetzt gerade noch einen Auswechselsper braucht, der zumindest keine Eigentore schießt. Ich bin bereit. Also ich muss sagen, ich weiß nicht, ich bin vielleicht aber einfach ein Opfer für diese ganze Social-Media-Aktion, die im Vorfeld liefen, die Bewerbung der Trikots, die ganzen Insights in den Homeground, da wo die gerade sind, untergebracht bei dir in der Nähe, wo du herkommst, Herzogen Augach, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch nicht in der Nähe, Bayern ist dann doch grösser als man denkt, aber ich bin da wirklich, ich feiere das gerade, ich gucke mir da alles an, freue mich sehr für die, bin auch ein Riesenfan der Schotten gewesen, die waren hier in Köln, haben ganz Köln übernommen, mit ihren Dudelsäcken und Fanmärschen, habe mich sehr wohlgefühlt hier, es war richtig toll, hat mich richtig gefreut, die haben auch über Köln toll gesprochen, haben geholfen, die Parks nachher wieder aufzuräumen, gibt so lustige Videos bei TikTok, wie sie dann so, wie so ein Schotter so sagt, ihr stellt uns hier die Parks zur Verfügung, er ist offensichtlich sehr betrunken, ich stell uns hier die Parks zur Verfügung und dann räumt ihr so einen Bierkasten und räumt ihr die Flaschen wieder ein, wie so der, den man nach einer WG-Party, der bis zum Ende bleibt, wo man denkt, ja, kannst du auch gehen, ich krieg das schon hin. Den schottischen machen. Den schottischen machen, so, nämlich nicht gehen, ohne Schuss zu sagen, sondern eben mitzuhelfen, bei der Party aufzuräumen. Lustig übrigens, dass es in der Schweiz den französischen machen heißt. Okay, wenn man abhaut. Und in England den irischen Abgang. Bei uns ist es ja der polnische. Weiß ich überhaupt nicht, ob man das noch sagt. Würde man jetzt mal alle Länder der Welt und deren Sprichwörter auf dem Tisch liegen, ist es ein grosser Kreis oder gibt es doch Häufungen, dass manche Länder doch häufiger damit assoziiert werden, einfach spurlos zu verschwinden? Es gibt ja auch eine Karte mit Who's most likely to be the butt of the joke? Also welches Land ist am ehesten Ziel eines Witzes bei euch? Und bei uns ist es Polen, kennt man ja, die Polen-Witze, ein bisschen outdated wahrscheinlich, würde man jetzt nicht mehr so häufig hören, aber war eher der Witz. Dann natürlich die Engländer über die Iren oder Schotten und umgekehrt. Und es war schon häufig, und wir sind unten irgendwo in Kroatien oder sowas, lachen sie sich auch über uns kaputt, weil ich es sehr lustig finde, dass da irgendwo... Aber wir verstehen leider kein Wort. Es sind nämlich oft die Nachbarländer, weil sie ja verstehen durch so Rivalitäten oder sowas, naheliegend. Und wie die Holländer bei uns ja auch und umgekehrt. Aber dann Kroatien unten macht sich über uns die ganze Zeit lustig hinter unserem Rücken, weil da gibt es nämlich keine Chance für uns das zu hören und zu verstehen. Und wir verstehen es auch leider nicht. Nein. Wir auch diese ganzen kroatischen Hits, die sonst so aus diesem herrlichen Land kommen,
können wir nicht verstehen. Ich würde gerne wissen,
was denn daran? Was ist an uns
so lustig? Vielleicht kannst du es in Kroatien mal
erklären. Ja, das ist eigentlich schön. Das ist ein schönes
Format. Was ist das Klischee über mich?
Also auch für so andere Sachen, wenn du jetzt
sagst, keine Ahnung, du bist jetzt irgendwie
Fechten, du machst Fechten. Genau. Und dann denkst
du dir so, was ist das Klischee über mich so? Weil du weißt
es gar nicht. Gehst du anderen Leuten hin? Weil du weißt oft, was die Klischees von anderen Leuten sind, aber nicht was deine eigenen sind. Wieso ist das Fechten so richtig? Habe ich mir einfach überlegt, als Hobby. Okay, du, also deine Frage ist jetzt, wenn ich richtig verstehe, was ist an mir das Klischee, wenn ich fechte? Genau. Es gibt im Fechten gerade den grossen Betrugsskandal deswegen habe ich überlegte einzusteigen weil da tatsächlich ist anscheinend relativ simpel ist die schiedsrichter zu bestechen weil das ist ja ein relativ kleiner Schwert hat und der schiedsrichter nicht richtig und das heißt du kannst wenn du den Gegner nicht triffst der schiedsrichter ist vergleichsweise leicht zu treffen weil der ist in der Regel nicht sehr sportlich und dann kannst du den einfach abstechen, solange bis du gewonnen hast, bis er dir den Sieg gibt. Und das ist ein grosses Problem im Fechtsport. Hat das mal jemand gemacht? Einfach das Schwert vom Gegner weg an die Kehle des Schiedsrichters und gesagt, okay, wer hat gewonnen. Ist ja gefährlich, ja, ist tatsächlich gefährlich. Eigentlich müsste man immer, ich finde der Schiedsrichter muss immer, und das beim Tennis clever gemacht, er hat keinen Schläger, um sich zu verteidigen, deswegen hat er den Hochsitz. Ist der Hochsitz denn so hoch gebaut, dass man mit Schläger nicht, also dass er genau nicht mehr rankommt? Der Hochsitz ist immer, das ist eine Regel im internationalen Tennissport, so hoch, dass der grösste Spieler des Turniers mit ausgestrecktem Tennis, Schläger und springend nicht rankommen kann. Das heisst, man muss es aber auch anpassen dem grössten Spieler nach. Und wenn eine neue Legende auf der Plattform erscheint, dann müssen sämtliche Hochsitze hochgeschraubt werden. Gerade auf der Tour ist der grösste Spieler, Novak Djokovic, mit seinen 1,98. Hat ein grosses Problem ergeben in vielen, weil tatsächlich ja auch viele lokale Tennisplätze nachgerüstet werden mussten tatsächlich. Ist ein Problem, ist ein Problem, kann man mal sagen. Ist ein Problem. Aber dafür sind Sie sicher, ja klar, Biathlon oder so ist das ein großes Problem. Da kannst du einfach den Schießrichter abschießen. Also ich meine, das ist ein geniales Sportjahr dieses Jahr. Ja, wir haben EM im eigenen Land, wir haben die Olympiade in Paris. Ja, oh la la, oui oui, mes amis. Erstmal vielen Dank an das Intro. Vielen Dank an, so und jetzt wird's interessant, an Kyrill. Entspann euch alle, jetzt wird's spannend, weil ihr, bis jetzt war's locker. Es ist ja locker und uninteressant, aber jetzt wird's interessant. Kyrill, sendet ihr uns dieses herrliche Intro aus unserem liebsten Nachbarland, auch wir haben Franzosenwitze? Was denn? Dass sie Frosch-Schenkel essen,
Baguettes essen die ganze Zeit.
Viel Essen.
Kirill, aber mit K.
Wo es im Französischen ja kein K gibt.
Da ist es ja dann eher Cyril mit C.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt ein
versteckter Hinweis auf eine französische
Identität ist,
oder Zuneigung zumindest,
oder andersrum. Ich weiß es nicht genau. So oder so. Erstmal schöner Name. Merci, Kyril. Sehr schöner Name, kommt glaube ich ein bisschen aus dem Griechischen, wo Kyrios der Herr ist, altgriechisch, der rechte Herr Gebieter. In diesem Sinne, wir verbeugen uns vor dir, Gebieter Kyril. Ich finde es einen sehr schönen Namen. So, jetzt möchte ich mal eine Grundsatzdiskussion kurz führen, kurz was organisatorisches, Grundsatzdiskussion, das Podcast UFO in eigener Sache. Ich habe jetzt schon ein paar Podcasts nämlich gehört, dass Leute jetzt anfangen, immer ein anderes Intro zu nehmen und damit haben wir wirklich angefangen. Sternchen, wenn man eine krasse These macht und da jetzt auch nicht ins Detail gehen will, damit, dass man falsch liegt, Sternchen. Ich bin ja ohnehin für eine Prozentregelung, dass wenn du sagst, weil es gibt immer Ausnahmen, so die Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regeln, dass wenn du sagst, wir waren die Ersten, dann reicht es, wenn wir unter den ersten fünf Prozent der Podcasts waren. Lass uns aber für alles zehn Prozent sagen, fertig. Zehn Prozent. Ich liebe das so doll. Und dann passt es schon. Weil ja, es gibt immer irgendwie den ersten Podcast der Welt, 1872 oder so, wo dann irgendwie Beethoven das Intro gemacht hat. Man sagt ja auch Dinge für eine gute Stimmung, für einen interessanten Fact. Und wenn man immer die Einschränkungen macht, dann landet man in so einem Bundestagspolitiker-Blabla oder Juristen-Blabla, wo wirklich jedes Detail zählt, in einer normalen Konversation ja nicht, ich liebe die Regeln so doll. Ja, wenn du sagst, oh geil, Feldsalat ist der beste Salat, so, unter den besten zehn Prozent. Für dich unter den besten zehn Prozent. Das reicht, man muss es nicht so ganz präzise machen. So fantastisch und ohne Scheiß, ja, super, geil. Also wir waren die Ersten, die das gemacht haben. So, ja, wir waren die Ersten, die das völlig möglich. Also wir waren die Ersten, die das gemacht haben und jetzt fangen halt alle, ja, kurz Abhustpause. Könnt ihr auch gerne machen, mal die Ohren reinigen. Auf der anderen Seite. Wir sind immer noch, du bist immer noch krank, du hast die längste Krankheit der Welt. Das ist so unangenehm. Oder ist das der neue Normalzustand? Ja, ich glaube, es haben sich sehr viele Krankankheiten in einer reihe gestellt dann irgendwann haben sie mein immunsystem so sehr in die kniegezwungen ich glaube übrigens dass das die allergie war allergie ist ja korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch liege gerne unter den zehn prozent es muss zehn prozent nah näher an der wahrheit sein als das gegenteil um uns zu korrigieren ergo zehn prozent unter zehn prozent des wahrheitlichen Anteils jetzt liegen. Allergie ist ja eine Überreaktion des Immunsystems auf Dinge, die gar nicht so gefährlich sind für den Körper, ja. Und ich glaube, dass mein Immunsystem so doll geschwächt wurde durch die Allergie, dass Krankheiten, die alle in einer Reihe standen, gesagt haben, können wir hier rein,
können wir hier rein, wir sind ein Club, natürlich
der war abgelenkt von der Allergie. Aber wo warten
die Krankheiten? Also wo ist denn die
Sandkordel des Körpers?
Ich glaube, im Mund öffnig. Dass die alle so im Ohr,
alle so im Gehörgang der Reihe nach stehen,
so in so einem Tunnel. Körperöffnungen. Und die
halten auch Abstand und einer nach dem anderen?
Primär im Mund stelle ich mir das vor.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man durch die Nase Erreger aufnimmt. Durch den Mund und durch die Augen. Man atmet die Augen. Durch das riesige Loch, das man in der Mitte des Auges hat. Ja, genau. Bei den Augenlöchern und das große Mundloch. Und dann nehmen wir das auf. Und dann sind die alle dann da und dann ist auch eine grosse Menge da. Immunsystem ist aber on und zerstört manche Sachen und hält die fern. Allergie hat mich runtergerockt und dann zack zack alle rein, alle rein und jetzt bin ich seit zwei Wochen, drei Wochen inzwischen schon unglaublich krank und hasse das sehr. Von daher sorry, wir müssen Abhustpause machen.
Das ist okay.
So, das ist okay.
Jetzt wollten wir aber auch was...
Können wir dir irgendwas Gutes tun? Soll ich dich massieren oder streicheln? Thema, habe ich gerade keine Möglichkeit, leider. Dann gar nichts. Tut mir leid. Und deswegen möchte ich sagen, ich möchte die Frage stellen an euch da draußen und an dich, jetzt wo alle quasi User-Generated-Intros haben. Ja. Ich habe so viele Podcasts damit angefangen und es ist sau nervig, weil jetzt sind wir nichts mehr Besonderes.
Man kann leider nicht immer sagen,
ist euer Intro jetzt
KI generiert oder halt
kommt es wirklich von euch. Es ist nicht mehr
zu sagen. Ja, ist ein Thema, ist ein Thema.
Sorry, Kyrill, aber es ist ein grossen
Respekt, wenn es von dir ist, aber es klang ein bisschen
KI generiert. So, aber
ein Thema beginnt.
Kapitel eins, Prolog. Ja, okay. Also,
es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir
viele KI-Einsendungen bekommen. Mittlerweile
Vielen Dank. Nein, so, aber ein Thema beginnt. Kapitel eins, Prolog. Also, es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir viele KI-Einsendungen bekommen. Mittlerweile lehne ich die ab. Wenn ich sie erkenne, lehne ich sie ab und sage, ey danke, aber wir kriegen einfach zu viele. Wir würden einfach nur noch KI-Intros haben und die klingen alle gleich, die klingen alle identisch. Und ich finde, da gehen so ein bisschen die sehr charmanten, handgemachten Intros unter.
Deswegen bin ich noch nicht ganz bereit, das offiziell zu sagen, aber in eigener Sache mache ich das schon. Ich sage eher, ey, wundere dich nicht, wenn wir es nicht nehmen, weil es hat dich jetzt auch wirklich nur 20 Sekunden gekostet.
Ich will ja gar nicht zu nahe treten, aber ich kann verstehen, wenn man sich Mühe gibt und so.
Fussnote im Prolog. Es ist schon eine Fussnote drin.
Ja, eine gelbe Seite. Genau, unten so eine lange Fussnote, die länger ist als die Seite. So, Achtung kurz, eins, Fussnote eins. Kann man nicht bei allen KI generierten Dingen irgendwo, weil jetzt mal ganz abstrakt gesprochen, alles, was ein Computer gener generiert sind Nullen und Einsen. Sehen wir alle Nullen und Einsen? Ich glaube nicht. Können da nicht, pass auf, pass auf, pass auf, es kommt irgendwo hin, es kommt jetzt. Mein Kopf ist gerade explodiert, sorry, ich muss kurz nochmal meine Gehirnrinde aufsappeln. Wir sind in der theoretischen Philosophie, wir sind abstrakte theoretische Philosophie und du musst kurz bei mir bleiben. Das musst du jetzt glauben. Okay, ich bin dabei, 10%-Regel, ich bin dabei. Suspension of disbelief und dann komme ich an einen Punkt, der glaube ich spannend ist. Ein Wasserzeichen im Code, im Nullen- und Einsen-Code, dass es eine Pflicht ist, dass in allen KI-generated Sachen immer diese eine Folge drin ist, die für alle Sachen, zum Beispiel, du öffnest eine Wave-Datei oder eine MP3-Datei und da ist im Hintergrund so ein kleiner Roboter zu sehen. Und das ist immer so ein Wasserzeichen, was der Computer dir anzeigt, weil egal, du erkennst es immer und der muss auch quasi, wenn du einen Screenshot machst von einem KI generierten Bild, muss da drin quasi versteckt sein, nur für Computer erkennt. Versteckt, man kann es im blossen Auge nicht sehen. Genau, im blossen Auge erkennen, das meine ich, irgendwo versteckt sein, dass dein Computer sofort was markiert. Aber jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was ist, wenn du deine KI sagst, ey bitte generiere mir ein Punkrockartiges Intro-Lied, aber ohne Wasserzeichen. Und dann macht er Brrrr. Nein, das ist alles möglich. Du kriegst ja auch, es gibt ja EU-Richtlinien auch für Bananen, wie bei Bananen zu sein haben. Da ist ja auch nicht immer der eine Giftstoff drin, wenn du mal willst. Nein, nein, es muss klar reguliert sein. Du kannst ja auch, das sind ja keine Wild-West-Firmen, die Leute umbringen können oder andere Rechtmäßigkeiten überschreiten können für ihren hehren Zweck. Nein, die können ja nicht alles machen. Also du forderst das digitale Wasserzeichen für KI. Ja, und Computer geben es ja hinzuerkennen.
Ja, tatsächlich, glaube ich, gibt es sowas in der Art, tatsächlich, dass Also du forderst das digitale Wasserzeichen für KI. Und Computer geben es ja hin zu erkennen.
Tatsächlich, glaube ich, gibt es sowas in der Art, dass man das irgendwie rausfinden kann. Aber das ist natürlich so ein Wettrüsten, dass beide Seiten Interesse haben, dass man es nicht erkennen kann usw. Nur um das abzudrücken, ich würde gerne sagen, KI nicht. Aber ich finde gerade die Existenz von KI macht ja die handgemachten Intros, finde ich, noch wertvoller. Exakt. Ich freue mich ja tatsächlich noch mehr, wenn tatsächlich jemand die echte Ukulele in die Hand nimmt, anstatt auf ukuleleki.de dann das einzugeben. Deswegen freue ich mich tatsächlich jetzt noch mehr über unsere tollen User-Intros. Oder nutzt KI als, habe ich fast versprochen, nutzt es als Mittel, um eure handgemachten Intros besser zu machen? Auch gerne. Da wird es dann natürlich haarig, weil ich bin jetzt auch nicht der Beste im Erkennen. Das heißt, es kann gut sein, dass ich schon manche gelöscht habe, die gar nicht kei waren oder andersrum, manche durchgeschlüpft sind. Von denen ich glaube, ich will jetzt keine Kyrill, ja, du hast den Namen schon genannt. Nein, nein, ich will keine. Doch, du hast den Namen aber bereits genannt vor zehn Minuten. Namen nennen, aber wenn Leute. Du hast den Namen Kirill bereits genannt. Mit einem Baguette in der Hand. Vielleicht aufpassen. Ja, aber bei Kirill sollen jetzt Kapitel zwei, wir sind Prolog dann Kapitel zwei. Ja, eins wurde geschwärzt. Kirill hat ja eine computergenerierte Stimme benutzt, das ist aber nicht das gleiche wie KI. Wenn du jetzt, sag ich mal, stimmlich nicht begabt bist. Kirill, du hast ganz tolle Talente. Ich könnte sie jetzt alle aufzählen, aber das würde den Rahmen dieser Podcastaufnahme bei weitem springen. Und deswegen hast du dich einer computergenerierten Stimme bedient, das ist in Ordnung. Erlaubt. Das kann ja auch ein komödiantischer Effekt sein, hin und wieder. So, Kapitel drei. Was auch für mich schon das letzte Kapitel wäre, aber ich lasse dir noch ein Epilog offen.
Wollen wir nicht als Podcast-UFO sozusagen den Schritt, weil ich habe, jetzt sind wir gefühlt hinten dran, die Gegenwart hat uns eingeholt, jetzt haben das irgendwie alle, jetzt haben alle, sei es KI oder nicht, User-Generated Intros. Immer andere. Wollen wir jetzt nicht wieder, und wäre das nicht spannend, merken wir mal die Idee, wollen wir jetzt nicht ein neues Intro und das machen dann die Babelsberger Symphoniker, spielen uns das ein, wollen wir das nicht mal jetzt in Angriff nehmen und da möchte ich euch mit reinholen, weil ihr so viel für uns getan habt. Und natürlich ist diese Ära Intros jetzt irgendwie spannend gewesen, es gab viele tolle Highlights, es gab auch ein paar dunkle Folgen, aber es wäre natürlich jetzt, ich möchte jetzt irgendwie jetzt alle reinholen und sagen, wollen wir nicht gemeinschaftlich jetzt als das Podcast-So-Podcast-Community-Event-Projekt sagen, wir suchen uns wieder ein richtiges Intro. Du führst ja als Argument an, dass das jetzt alle machen, in Anführungszeichen, aber wir haben das ja nicht gemacht, weil es einzigartig ist, sondern weil wir unsere Community lieben. Würden wir das jetzt wieder rückgängig machen, was wäre das für ein Zeichen? Außerdem haben wir wirklich noch eine Schlange. Wo ist die Grenze? Pass auf, mein Problem ist ein sehr praktisches. Es gibt jetzt sage ich mal noch ein, also wie, lass uns verdeutlichen mit deinen Krankheiten die Schlange stehen. Es gibt wirklich die letzten 50 Plätze. Nur um zu verstehen, du vergleichst gerade unsere Community, die sich wirklich stundenlang, tagelang hingesetzt haben, um Interess zu machen mit Krankheiten. Zur Illustration. Wenn wir jetzt sagen würden, ab heute keine User-Interess mehr, müssten wir jetzt noch alle verwenden, die wir schon haben. Die wir gut finden. Und da sind jetzt aber, da ist ein gewisser Bodensatz, ich will es gar nicht wertend. Bodensatz ist nicht wertend gemeint.
Die Krümelkiste, ich will gar nicht jetzt sagen
die Ramschkiste, aber
der stete Strom an neuen
Intros erlaubt es mir natürlich, die
ein wenig nach hinten zu verlagern.
So, dass du
sozusagen die neuen frischen reinnehmen kannst.
Und ich habe ein bisschen
Angst vor dieser Lawine,
vor den unteren 50 der Datei,
des Ordners, weil die müssten wir
alle erstmal durchackern und das wird eine harte
Das war's. Mhm. Und ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor dieser Lawine, vor den unteren 50 der Datei, des Ordners, weil die müssten wir alle erstmal durchackern und das wird eine harte Zeit. Aber wo reden wir hier? Reden wir von 1000, reden wir von 50, reden wir von zwei? Wir reden von Leuten, die mit der flachen Hand auf die Wand schlagen, mehrere Male und dann sagen das Podcast-UFO und dann schicken wir uns das ein und das ist nett und das ist Intros, Bodensatz, gottlosen Bodensatzintros reden wir hier? Das weiß ich nicht. Das habe ich nicht im Blick. Können wir nicht so eine Papierkorbfolge machen, wo wir die alle spielen? Ja, da müsste ich jetzt wirklich mit der Kerze ins Archiv gehen und dann nochmal ganz tief, das ist ja alles auch sicher. Das ist ja sicher. Diese alten Folianten nochmal wälzen und so. Nein, ich freue mich immer über die neuen Intros, aber wenn jetzt die Community wirklich deinem polemischen, sehr polemischen Aufruf folgt, dann kann man darüber reden, aber da müsste natürlich Uwe Bartels sich auch mal endlich melden. Genau. Uwe, jetzt mal direkt an dich. Die Handynummer ist immer noch die gleiche. Ich habe Stefan testweise angerufen, um zu checken, ob die Handynummer funktioniert und sie hat funktioniert. Der Crazy Frog war zu hören. Klaus Badelt, so. Ich hatte nämlich... Wie? Klaus... Oh nein! Wir haben an uwe.badl geschrieben. Klaus, genau, das wäre die Frage, wenn der Komponist von Flutter Karibik Teil 1 uns ein Intro schreiben könnte.
Ich fände das immer noch absolut fantastisch, wenn er jemanden Kontakt hat, gerne schicken, dann glaube ich sind alle, ich möchte nur eine Diskussion aufmachen, lass uns das als Gemeinschaftsprojekt diesen Diskurs mal kurz öffnen, wollen wir nicht ein episches, episches Intro haben, was wir immer hören, an das wir uns verlieben. Aber nicht vergessen, auch Asterix und Obelix, Au Service de sa Majesté, hat er auch den Soundtrack gemacht. Also nicht nur Flute, Kyrillik. Genau. Das ist natürlich eine Diskographie, die mehr ... Diskographie. Oder sagt man das nicht so? Aber ist das nicht das... Bei Filmmusik finde ich Diskographie... Das Opus eines Musikers ist doch die Diskographie, oder? Ja, nee, nee, von Popmusikern oder Rockmusikern würde ich Diskographie sagen. Ja, bei Klaus, da sagt man Opus dann, glaube ich, aber an sich ist es ja nicht die Bibliographie, sondern... Aber du hast recht, die Diskographie von Beethoven klingt ein bisschen komisch. Jetzt finde ich wiederum sowas wie, wie hast du gerade gesagt, zu SchriftstellerInnen? Die Bibliographie? Ja, aber das finde ich zum Beispiel hochgegriffen, führt zu was, weiss ich nicht, wie Frank Schätzing oder sowas. Die Bibliographie, nee, dann schreibt er einfach Bücher, die er geschrieben hat. Die, wo er geschrieben hat. Die, woie, ja, können wir uns entspannen. Thomas Mann hat eine Bibliografie. Ja, okay. Naja, noch ein bisschen albern. Ähm, genau. Also, Klaus. Ich meine nur, Klaus. Gar nicht jetzt wertend. Ich möchte die Frage stellen, so möchte ich es formulieren. Wie, also was hast du gegen Kirill,, dass dich das jetzt dazu verleidet hat, das komplette, also was du gerade machst ist, du hörst ein Lied und stellst die Existenz von Musik in die Frage. Ich wollte das seit mehreren Folgen ansprechen. War es so schlecht? Es trifft jetzt nur Kyrill, ausnahmsweise, aber das ist nur sinnbildlich, es trifft jetzt nur exemplarisch Kyrill, ich wollte das schon wochenlang ansprechen, spätestens bei Jakob, aber ich wollte es nur ansprechen, weil es mir schon ein paar Mal aufgefallen ist, dass jetzt so die Großen, so fest und flauschig, hat jetzt jede Woche ein anderes Intro, selbst die sogenannte Gegenwart, hat jedes Wochenendes Intro. Ja, okay. Ich brauche das nicht mehr, ich möchte das nicht mehr hören und ich möchte, dass wir jetzt wieder den nächsten Schritt wagen. Ich will, dass wir die Zukunft schäpen und Und jetzt mit einem coolen Intro, irgendwie das erste Orchester gemachte Intro von einem coolen Komponisten, Komponistin, irgendwie, die man vielleicht sogar kennt, fände ich ja so geil. Deswegen halt eine Frage, wenn wir einen epischen Composer bekommen, wäre es okay, wenn das Babelsberger Filmorchester das einspielt, dass das unser neues Intro ist? Ich würde aber trotzdem gerne noch unsere Community mit reinholen. Es muss ja nicht ein Intro sein. Es kann ja ... Outro. Ja, das ist natürlich verlockend. Wir sind der erste Podcast mit Community-Autos. Oder halt sowas wie, also bei Comedy Bang Bang zum Beispiel gibt es den Catchphrase, den Listener Catchphrase, der sehr, sehr cool ist tatsächlich. Oder halt irgendwie eine Art Cold Opener oder sowas. Kleiner Ausschnitt oder ein 16-minütiger Sketch oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, was man locker einfach gut davorsteigen kann. Da überlegen wir uns was, aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, es steht im Feld leider mit Klaus Bahndt und müssen wir Klaus auch noch mal ins Gewissen reden, dass der halt, wenn nochmal, Volker Bertelmann hat den Oscar bekommen für im Westen nichts Neues, drunter würde ich es ungern machen, das Podge, da kommen wir, mit Hallo, Hallo, Hallo, Hallo, Hallo, Hallo, Hallo, Jesus, endzeitlich, aber wir müssen den Schritt weitergehen, ich glaube, da seid ihr dabei. Das wollte ich nur sagen, es trifft jetzt leider Kyrill, aber das war jetzt gar nicht so gemeint. Kyrill hat einen tollen Job gemacht, ich fand das Intro super. Je suis Kyrill, wir stehen alle hinter Kyrill. Wir stehen alle hinter Kyrill, selbst ich als jetzt der Buhmann, ich weiß, aber es braucht kurz jemanden die Fraustaus. Ich verstehe, gut, dass du innovieren willst. Und tatsächlich, vielleicht können wir ja auch noch mal, weil es wurmt mich ein bisschen, dass du gewinnst gerade. Das wurmt mich ein bisschen. Womit? Und zwar vor vielen, vielen Folgen haben wir Position bezogen, wir haben ja Stellung bezogen. Ah, ich lieb, was jetzt kommt. Und ich erinnere mich sogar noch dran. Ja. Pizza? Nee. Oh, okay. Da habe ich auch recht gehabt. Da habe ich auch gewonnen. Nee, okay. Gleich. Nein. Und zwar haben wir versucht, die Zukunft vorherzusagen und zu sagen, welcher Modus wird die Zukunft haben. Und du hast gesagt, künstliche Intelligenz. Wann? Und du hast gesagt, die Zukunft wird geprägt werden von künstlicher Intelligenz. Das habe ich wahrscheinlich gesagt, nachdem JTBT irgendwie überall ist, in aller Munde. Und ich habe damals gesagt, nein, ich glaube, die Zukunft wird geprägt sein von Zufall. Ja, random. Random, dass du eher zufällig generierte Inhalte konsumierst und nicht künstlich intelligente. Das war vor einigen Jahren. Ihr erinnert euch natürlich die Bücher-Bestsellerliste, Günther Rönellenfitsch, Platte Tüte. Als die Intros noch toll waren. Wie gesagt, nichts gegen ... Und du hast gewonnen. Du hast gewonnen mit KI und deswegen tatsächlich für mich vielleicht eine Möglichkeit, den Zufall wieder ein bisschen aufleben zu lassen, weil ich glaube an den Zufall. Ich glaube, dass der Zufall einiges leisten kann. Ich liebe den Zufall. Dass du brauchen wir da auch noch bessere technische Mittel, dass du jetzt gar nicht sagst, keine Ahnung, du sagst jetzt, hey, ChatGBT, schreib mir meinen Einkaufszettel. Genau. So, und dann gibt er dir einen sinnvollen Einkaufszettel. Aber das ist langweilig, weil der denkt, der kennt dich, ah, du bist den, den, du bist so alt, hast den Geschmack. Und es ist immer der Schlüssel, es ist Antithese, Synthese. Moment. Ich habe die These aufgestellt. Du kannst nicht aus Antithese direkt zur Synthese gehen. Ich habe jetzt übersprungen, dass du die These, ich die Antithese und jetzt die Synthese. Es sei denn, du machst aus der Antithese und der Synthese wiederum eine Synthese. Eine Synthese. Das geht. Ich möchte nur sagen, die Synthese aus uns beiden ist nämlich, glaube ich, Achtung, das wird wichtig noch in ein paar Jahren, gewerteter Zufall. Okay. Entschuldigung, nochmal, nochmal, shit. Kann man nicht gerne? Ich habe mich versprochen, das ist genau der Moment in History, wo man funktionieren muss und ich habe versagt. I blew it. Gewichteter Zufall, gewichteter Zufall, das ist nämlich entscheidend. Die Einkaufsliste, komplett random, nicht lustig. Die Einkaufsliste an sich ist ja auch schon eine Gewichtung. Wo willst du denn sozusagen, der Prompt an sich ist ja schon ein das und das will ich. Und ich glaube, dass ein unterhaltsame, cooler Zufall ist, muss mit einer gewissen Gewichtung reinkommen. Und da glaube ich kommt die Mischung, da muss nämlich dann wieder künstliche Intelligenz rein, weil es ist nur der Zufall ist gar nicht so toll. Der Zufall in eine gewisse Richtung macht es lustig und erhaltsam fun. Deswegen gewichteter, gewichteter Zufall.
Ich weiss nicht, ich glaube, ich bin der Purist. Ich bleibe weiterhin bei Zufall. Ich glaube, wenn du ne, also zum Beispiel, stell dir zum Beispiel ne App vor, wo du Einkaufslisten machst und der fügt immer noch ein zufälliges Objekt hinzu.
Ist nicht lustig, ist gar nicht lustig. Es muss ja auch nicht lustig sein, Stefan Tietze. Warum willst du es dann haben? Weil ich meinen Horizont erweitern möchte, weil ich sage, ah Moment mal, Sauerkraut, habe ich lange nicht mehr gegessen, nehme ich mit rein. Wohlgegen die KI hätte das nicht gewusst. Nein, dein Zufallprogramm würde dann reinschreiben, ein Lamm. Ein ganzes Lamm.
Ja, okay.
Und dann stehst du dann im Rewe und sagst ...
Und wo kriegst du ein Lamm her?
Ja, dann stehst du dann im Rewe und sagst dann so bei der Frischetheke so, Entschuldigung, ein ganzes Lamm.
Entschuldigung, wie bitte?
Ich sag gerne ein ganzes Lamm. Ein ganzes Lamm.
Das haben wir leider nicht. Wir haben Wiener Würstchen, Fleischwürstchen, Hackfleisch, Mettfleisch, Pastete. Und schon ist deine Erfahrung scheisse. Wenn aber gewichteter Zufall, du gibst nämlich den Prompt ein, es muss im Rewe erhältlich sein. Und dann hast du nämlich plötzlich ein Produkt, mit dem du gar nicht gerechnet hast, was du dann einpackst und dann hast du nämlich die coole Erfahrung, erweitert am Horizont. Ja, mein Interesse ist ja, ich will ja hintenrum Geld verdienen, dadurch, dass Firmen das sponsern können. Ja, das habe ich schon verstanden. Dass der User denkt, es sei Zufall, ist es aber nicht. Ja. Es ist aber nicht. Aber ich glaube auch Zufall, auch für Autoren oder so zum Beispiel, ist glaube ich das eine gute Möglichkeit, einfach Zufall. Weil ich habe mir letztens überlegt, dürfen Autoren überhaupt Sprichwörter benutzen oder Redensarten? Wem gehören die? Weil die sind ja eigentlich, die Aufgabe eines Autoren ist es ja, Dinge neu auszudrücken. Einfach irgendein Gefühl oder ein Erlebnis oder irgendwas neu auszudrücken, neue Worte zu klein. Das ist eine spannende Definition des Jobs. Na klar, das kann ja sonst jeder. Der Vorhang ist blau, das kann jeder schreiben. Aber der Autor, der überlegt sich da was. Da sind wir jetzt bei Thomas Mann. Ich glaube, mich an einen Satz zu erinnern, zum Beispiel, der Wald ist dunkel. Das kann jeder schreiben.
Ich finde ihn nicht so schlecht.
Aber was schreibt Thomas Mann? Thomas Mann schreibt, dass dunkel waldet.
Ah ja. Es macht es halt immer schwieriger zu verstehen. Es macht schwieriger zu verstehen, aber deswegen liest man ja gerne. Gerne folge ich dir nicht so ganz in dieser Definition. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du einen Roman schreibst und dann sagt jemand, damit habe ich nicht gerechnet, der blieb mir ein Klos im Hals hängen, ich hatte ein Klos im Hals. Da sage ich eigentlich Stopp, würde ich rot anstreichen. Gibt's schon. Du bist Schriftsteller, du musst was Neues ausdenken. Nicht Klos im Hals. Es kann doch tausend Sachen im Hals haben. Du denkst du technisch, die Makroebene, die muss ja neu sein. Auch die Mikroebene. Ja, aber dann kannst du ja sagen, ah, du hast benutzt, die meisten Wörter habe ich schon mal in einem anderen Roman gelesen. Dann kannst du ja bei Musik auch sagen, C-Dur haben auch jetzt schon alle gemacht. Nee, nee, Wörter gehen schon, Wörter sind die Bausteine, damit muss man arbeiten. Aber Satze sind ja auch Bausteine eines Buches. Aber in den Redensarten, also wirklich, es lief ihm eiskalt den Rücken runter. Wenn ich das in einem Buch lese, sage ich, das ist ein schlechtes Buch, weil denkt dir doch was Neues aus. Sagt doch, der Rücken gletscherte. So was, ja, oder irgendwas in der Art. Aber nicht so was, was es schon gibt. Ich finde, das ist eine Art von Plagiat. Und da schaue ich auch dich an. Die Steinlawine aus dem Herzen. So was. Die füllen ein Stein vom Herzen. Richtig, genau.
Ja, so was in der Richte.
Lawinenartig fielen Steine von seiner...
Ziegelsteinartig, die Kölner Innenstadt ziegelte in seinem Herzen. Okay, gut. Also ich freue mich jetzt schon auf seinen Debütroman, der sehr anstrengend wahrscheinlich wird, zu lesen. Ich habe aber eine neue Zukunftsprognose. Okay. Oder wolltest du noch weiter, wolltest du auf was hinaus? Nö, nö, ich ... Ich wollte ... Nein, um ehrlich zu sein, ich wollte speziell dir ins Gewissen reden, dass du als Autor bitte keine Redensarten mehr benutzt. Und da dachte ich zum Beispiel, da könnte Zufall, weil da würde ich als Firma, ich denke als Firma, ich bin Geschäftsmann, da könnte ich Autorinnen und Autoren, könnte ich helfen, könnte ich sagen, ah, ich habe ein Klos im Hals, lass uns die Zufallsmaschine anwerfen, ich habe ein Lamm im Hals, schreib doch einfach Lamm im Hals. Und der Leser denkt sich, hä, warum Lamm? Und dann passiert das ja im Kopf des Lesers. Ist lustig, weil meine Beobachtung ist tendenziell, dass bei Serien und Filmen der Zufall eher was Schlechtes ist. Also ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr
so Branchen-Talk oder
was glaube ich, was ich
gelernt habe beim Schreiben.
Oh bitte, Branchen-Talk, ich liebe es doch,
ich liebe ein bisschen an Branchen-Talk,
na bitte gib mir einen Branchen-Talk.
Nee, ich glaube nämlich,
dass, also sobald,
wenn ich etwas schlecht fand,
von eigenen Skripten oder anderen Skripten oder was auch immer, war es meistens, und ich wusste nicht genau warum, war es meistens die Willkür dahinter. Also wenn in einem Buch, in einem Drehbuch plötzlich eine Szene nicht funktioniert hat, habe ich mir überlegt, warum funktioniert die nicht, warum braucht man die nicht? Und es ist immer, sie ist nicht zwingend. Und zum Beispiel, warum ich Paul Thomas Anderson Filme so mag, um jetzt mal deinen Lieblingsfilm, The Will Be Blood, hinzuzuholen, jeder, jede Szene, obwohl es ein sehr, schon auch ein weird erzählter Film ist und charakterisch treffe, komische Entscheidungen und so, und irgendwie macht es ja auch seinen Flair aus, so ein bisschen so, weiss nicht, es sind sehr spezielle Charaktere immer. Aber es hat eine totale zwingende Erzählung.
Man versteht immer, warum sagt er das jetzt, warum denn die nächste Szene, warum die Abfolge hat sowas sehr, also natürlich passiert das jetzt, du stellst es nie in Frage, es ist nie eine fehlende Motivation oder sowas oder nicht genug gut genug hergeleitete Handlung. Und das ist bei Willkür immer das Problem.
Und ich glaube, bei schlechten Filmen, die du nicht magst, kann die Willkür viel erklären. Ja, okay, ich glaube, mir geht es auch eher um die sprachliche Ebene, dass du hast I drink your milkshake. Dass du nicht sagst, ich habe einen Frosch im Hals. Oder ich weiß gar nicht, welche gute Redensart. Ein das, das finde ich, das ist wie wenn du, wenn Musiker eine schon existierende Melodie benutzt, finde ich fahl. Ja, super, okay, nee, gehe ich mit, gehe ich mit. Wohingegen als Podcaster kannst du das machen. Ja, du bist ja kein Schriftsteller. Ist ein Bauchmedium, ist kein Kopfmedium, ist kein Handmedium, ist ein Ellenbogenmedium, auch manchmal. Auch, auch manchmal, da darf man nicht vergessen. vergessen. Manchmal ist ein Knie-Medium, manchmal muss man auch knien können, das ist klar.
Aber deswegen bitte mein Aufruf an alle Schriftstellerinnen und Schriftsteller, falls ihr gerade an was arbeitet, Debütroman oder sowas streicht, lief mir eiskalte Rücken runter, solche Sachen. Ich hatte ein trockenes Gefühl im Mund oder so, sag ich hatte ein Lamm im Hals. Das kann man sich, das fühlt man, so dieses
pelzige Lamm, das ist
finde ich ein gutes Gefühl, oder hatte ich einen Lamm
im Mund oder so.
Das finde ich fühlt man, Frosch im
Hals. Ja, also es fehlt so ein bisschen
diese, so eine Musiker
Lyrik.
Ich mag den Ausdruck Tired Starlings
mochte ich sehr in dem Song,
was kann man sagen, wie der Song heißt, White Room, genau, von Creamruck Tired Starlings, mochte ich sehr in dem Song, was kann man sagen, wie der Song heisst, White Room, genau, von Cream. Tired Starlings, finde ich so schön. Und das ist die ganze, das ganze Song hat so eine gewisse, weiß ich nicht, Lethargie und Tired Starlings bringt das so auf den Punkt. Ich meine, wenn man es mal grob übersetzt, was sind das, Spatzen? Nein, weiß ich es auch nicht, aber so aufgewe aufgeweckte Vögel. Und wenn die müde sind, warum sind die müde, die können ja schlafen, also irgendwie hat das was. Was ist denn passiert, dass sie plötzlich, dass sie schläfen, wenn sie müde sind? Ja, genau. Und wenn plötzlich die Spatzen, müde Spatzen, finde ich zum Beispiel einen sehr coolen Ausdruck, weil da merkt man, das steht für mehr, da ist viel mehr dahinter als dieser sinnleere Ausdruck. Pro müde Spatzen, kontra beleidigte Leberwurst. In der Stadt ist nichts los. So. In der Stadt ist nichts los. Ja. Pro müde Spatzen, selbst die Spatzen sind müde. Die klappen die Bordsteine hoch, so, schon hundert Mal gehört. Genau. Gib mir statt die beleidigte Leberwurst, gib mir beleidigte Mettwurst. In Bottrop kann man die Bürgersteige hochklappen. Nein. Da kannst du ab 21 Uhr die Bürgersteige hochklappen. In Bochum sind selbst die Tauben müd. So, müd. Wieder ein Buchstabe gespart. Yes. Und damit Druckkosten. Vielen Dank. Ich habe eine Prophezeiung, eine technische Prophezeiung. Ja, richtig. Gut. Ihr erinnert euch, ich war schon, lag schon richtig bei damals den Airpods, Airpods Pro mit Transparency Mode. Die haben den sogar so genannt. Wow. Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Aber jetzt habe ich eine neue Prophezeiung, und zwar intelligente Benachrichtigungen. Du kriegst zum Beispiel, weil es ist immer noch so, wir werden ja überhäuft, Slack macht, dann WhatsApp macht, iMessage macht was, Telegram, fucking Signal, genau, ICQ macht, oh, keine Lust mehr auf diese ganze Scheisse. und wir kriegen zu viele nachrichten auf unserem einen handy wir haben vier handys sterben aus dem alle einen handy kriegen sehr viele nachrichten und jetzt habe ich neulich nachrichten bekommen man ist sofort gestresst es vibriert am handy und dann guckt man drauf und es war nur jemand der auf etwas was man geschickt hat zum beispiel reagiert mit okay oder danke oder so einen daumen hoch Und das ist total krass, dass man immer noch, dass man quasi das gleiche Summen, die gleiche Unterbrechung, das gleiche bekommt für hallo meld dich mal kurz, ich bin gestürzt und hallo ich ertrinke Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe und ein Like auf einem Bild. Danke oder einen Daumen hoch auf dem Bild. Ja, machen wir so. Genau, machen wir so. Ja, wie gesagt, genau so.
Okay, also das Handy kennt dich so gut, dass es weiss, A, ertrinken und dann ganz laut und bei anderen Sachen nur ganz leise. Oh, das wird auch passieren. Der erste Schritt ist nur sowas wie Reaktionen, also bejahende Reaktionen oder so. Kann das Handy ja schon schnallen? Da sind wir ja weiter, Texterkennung sind wir ja so weit.
Das schnallt ein Handy.
Oder man kann zum Beispiel einstellen, dass ein Nichtstören-Modus, ausser wenn man Nachrichten mit einem Fragezeichen, die mit einem Fragezeichenenden bekommt, dass sie dann durchgehen. Das heißt sozusagen ein intelligenter Benachrichtigungsfilter. Also ich bin ja Gamer und ich spiele super gerne Spiele wie Dota 2 oder Warcraft 3 oder so. Weil mich interessiert der Aufbau-Charakter davon, dass du Items sammelst und dann halt immer stärker wirst und so. Und deswegen spiele ich die einfach gerne. Ja, und Weil du merk merkst mit der Zeit, dass du immer mehr Einfluss aufs Spiel nehmen kannst. Ja, und? Was ich sagen wollte, ich bin Gamer und ich überlege bei solchen Sachen immer sofort, wie könnte man es ausnutzen, wie könnte man Bugabuse, wie könnte man es ausnutzen und ich glaube, es würde dazu führen, dass Leute um Aufmerksamkeit kämpfen und dann automatisch sagen, ich will aber, dass Stefan das jetzt liest, alles klar und dann mache ich noch ein Fragezeichen dahinter oder ich würde halt immer sagen, okay, dann treffen wir uns um 15 Uhr, ich ertrinke Hilfe Hilfe. Das heisst, ich würde an das Ende von jeder Nachricht, ich ertrinke Hilfe, Hilfe schreiben, weil ich weiss, sonst liest du es nicht. Und dann, glaube ich, hast du ein Problem, weil dann weisst du nicht, aber du musst dich mit ergeben, diese Firewall zu durchbrechen, gerade wenn du den Mondmodus anhast beim iPhone, wenn du zweimal anrufst, geht es ja auch durch, weit für Notfall, für den Notfall muss es ja sozusagen den Notfallschlüssel gebenüssel geben, was ich meine. Und den kann man natürlich immer ausnutzen, aber es ist die Frage, sonst ist es halt einfach gefährlich. Ich möchte nur sagen, These, die gewichtete Intelligen, ich muss auch immer diesem Wort, das ist gerade wichtig, die intelligente Benachrichtigung. Gegenthese, der Sender kann selbst entscheiden, wie stark die Benachrichtigung stattfindet. Nach jedem Satz, den du schreibst, musst du bei, quasi jedes Enter ist ein, du musst selber bewerten, wie wichtig die Nachricht ist von eins bis zehn. Ja, finde ich gut, dass er einfach sagt, ich habe dein Bild geliked, hundert, volle Benachrichtigung. Oder halt, das Handy hebt ab, ein Meter in der Luft, einfach die Vibration ist so stark, oder halt eher zurückhaltend. Und dann überträgt es nämlich Introvertität und Extrovertität in die digitale Welt, weil ich als eher introverteter Typ würde jede Nachricht eher, Hilfe, Hilfe, ich trinke, nicht wichtig, nicht wichtig, ich will nicht stören, ich will nicht stören, ich will gar nicht stören, sorry, sorry.
Oder man könnte natürlich noch weitergehen. Ich denke immer so, irgendwann hat das Handy ja immer den Puls parat vom Schreiber oder wie schnell man tippt oder so, dass man daran erfasst, wie wichtig ist die Nachricht. Puls.
Puls, Schreibgeschwindigkeit, Druck, Schweiss an den Fingern, das kann das Handy riechen, das schnallt das Handy.
Schnallt das Handy. erfasst, wie wichtig ist die Nachricht. Puls, Schreibgeschwindigkeit, Druck, Schweiss an den
Fingern, das kann das Handy riechen,
das schnallt das Handy, und dann
kann man ja da ein Päckchen machen, ah, so
wichtig ist es. Aber ich finde, das ist eine gute Prognose
auf jeden Fall, gefällt mir sehr. Ja, das ist auch
eine Prognose technischer Natur.
Ich finde, da machen wir gerade extreme
Fortschritte in dieser Folge.
Wir klären viel.
Wir klären viel abschliessend, wie die Zukunft aussehen wird, das gefällt mir gut. Meine Prophezeiung ist, es gibt mehr Saures. Warum? Um sich mal wieder zu spüren? Ich glaube, es wird einfach generell eine Renaissance des Sauren wiedergeben. Weil der Centerschock ist gestorben. Centerschock ist gestorben. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Saure ist komplett zum Kinderkram degradiert worden. Ich habe letztendlich lange nachgedacht, wegen der gemischten Tüte oder so, und da haben wir nämlich gesprochen über Innovationsmüdigkeit der deutschen Südigkeitenindustrie, und da kam tatsächlich auch im Reddit immer wieder auf, Ahoi Brause. Ahoy Brause vor allem mit Fürst Pückler ist tot, Langlebe, Himbeer, Waldmeister, Zitrone als neuesten Reihgespann der Geschmacksrichtungen mit dem Ahoy Brause Eis.
Das wollte ich natürlich sofort probieren, das ist ein Sandwich, alles mit Waffeln bin ich eh dabei, habe ich nicht gefunden, ich habe nur die Becherversion gefunden, hat mir gut geschmeckt mit Brause, aber ich habe mit saurer Brause, Brause und Kribbeln. Und ich dachte mir wirklich, warum hat das in die Haute Couture noch nicht einen Zug gefunden, warum sieht man das so selten in wirklich Fünf-Sterne-Hotels und Spas, warum kriegt man da nicht irgendwie so saure Kügelchen rein oder so, warum ist das so verschmäht, die Zitrone ist allseits beliebt, aber wird ja oft auch bekämpft das Saure, ich glaube, wir finden das Saure, das Saure, das Saure neu. Sehr gut. Und deswegen bin ich stolz. Du nimmst zwei Anläufe und dann hast du es aber auch oft dann geschafft. Also ich muss dazu was vorlesen, weil ich möchte auch die Kritik an mir vorlesen. Sehr gut, ich finde das gut. Oder die Kritik, die wir erhalten, weil manchmal kommt halt auch Stuss aus uns heraus. Und zwar habe ich letzte Woche behauptet, dass mir in Deutschland der Innovationswille fehlt, geile, richtig geile Süssigkeiten zu machen. Ich finde, wir stehen da seit Jahren fest. Da habe ich eine Nachricht auf Instagram bekommen. Bezugnahme zur letzten Folge, du hast mal wieder etwas gesagt, was völlig diametral zur Realität ist. Ach, Direktnachricht an dich? Neue Süssigkeiten, Doppelpunkt, Knopper. Und hier sieht man, finde ich, anhand, ich könnte jetzt erkennen, anhand der Nachricht, wie es geschrieben ist, dass sie dringend gemeint ist.
Alles ist kleingeschrieben, sehr wütend gewirkt. Kein Komma weit und breit. Puls 180, kann ich jetzt schon sagen, und die Tastendruck war extrem.
Neue Süßigkeiten, Doppelpunkt, Knoppersriegel, drei verschiedene Sorten, Anutterriegel, Werthas Popcorn, drei verschiedene Sorten, Werthas Karamellbytes, Nimm zwei Soft und Cola, unzählige neue Katjesorten und Mischungen, die alle paar Monate kommen, Funny Frisch Crospers, Linsenchips, meine Lieblingschips, Kichererbsenchips, etc. Also, da war jemand wütend, da ist jemand sehr, sehr, sehr stolz, was gerade in Deutschland an Südschkeiteninnovation passiert. Aber ich finde, der User hat sich selbst verraten. Weil was macht er denn? Linsen-Chips, meine Lieblingschips. Erstens das, das disqualifiziert, aber was schreibt er denn? Der sagt, wie, das Kino bietet keine Innovation mehr. Es gibt doch Superman 3, es gibt doch Wolfman 5, es gibt doch die Expandables 3. So, weil was er nämlich sagt, Knoppers Riegel in drei Sorten, das ist gerade keine Innovation, mein Lieber. Und die wird ja auch nicht angenommen. Ich will da mal die Verkaufszahlen sehen. Also wo sind die Dinge, die wahnbrechend neu sind, so dass sie dann neben anderen Sachen immer im Regal stehen, weil man sie akzeptiert als was Neues, Cooles. Ich glaube, ich kritisiere auch gar nicht unbedingt die Marken, sondern vielmehr auch so die Deutschen sind auch so was haben wir eben mal schon gemacht. Und ich meine, ich möchte jetzt erst mal das Kritik so stehen lassen. Ne, ich will es nicht stehen lassen. Weil ich finde, allein die Tatsache, dass er die Innovationsmüdigkeit damit verteidigt, ist das Beste, der beste Beweis dafür, dass die Innovationsmüdigkeit herrscht. Wenn jemand sagt, hä, es gibt auch Innovationen, den Knoppersriegel, den Hanuterriegel, also das ist ja fast schon satirisch, das ist ja überspitzt. Die Verriegelung. Das ist die Verriegelung der deutschen Bussiswahnkultur. Es ist ja sinnvoll, es ist alles wie zum Riegel, lustigerweise metaphorisch auch ein gutes Wort, die Verriegelung. Sehr schön. Die Innovationsverriegelung. Sehr schön, sehr gut. Die Innovationsverriegelung. Wir machen ein riesen großes Schloss davor. Ja. Und Linsenchips, meine Lieblingschips. Aber also. Spätestens da hast du dich komplett disqualisiert. Also für mich disqualisiert. Ich wollte es eigentlich so stehen lassen und als Gegenthese ein Gegengewicht in diesem Podcast. Aber Linsenchips, meine Lieblingschips. Sorry. Sorry. Also, dann können wir es alles lassen. In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank für die Nachricht, schreibt doch gerne auch eure Meinung. Ne, es ist spannend, ich glaube, da ist noch was zu holen, das ist ja alles, was ich sage. Ja, auf jeden Fall, doch, total. Aber ich meine, es ist für mich eine der, und jetzt vielleicht wirbeln wir uns da in den Teufelskreis rein, aber für mich eine der wichtigsten Innovationen des Süssfachs war eigentlich Kit-Kat-Chunky. Zu sagen, du nimmst etwas in einer anderen, eigentlich ist es ja keine wirkliche Innovation, einfach zu sagen, du nimmst den kleinen Riegel von Kit-Kat und machst ihn gross. Aber das sind für mich so diese kleinen Geistesblitzmomente, wo ich sag, ja, genau das. Warum denn nicht einen riesigen Gummibären zum Beispiel, sowas in der Ecke gibt's ja. Wir haben ja damals versucht, mit guter Arbeit Originals den Schokogummibärriegel zu etablieren als Werbemittel. Das hat dann aufgrund von vielen, vielen Gründen nicht. Also die Liste würde in den Rahmen sprengen. Also die Pro, ich glaube Pro hatten wir drei, Contra 600 Argumente.
Aber allein, dass wir eine Maschine bekommen, also bekommen hätten, es kam mal irgendwann die Mail, ja wir müssen euch die Form gießen, unsere Maschinen umstellen.
Von Haribo.
Und allein, dass das schon eine Option war, bin ich schon spannend, dass es jemand in Erwägung gezogen hat, das zu tun.
So gut. Aber wir hätten halt mindestens 800 Tonnen bestellen müssen.
Und da war dann das ZDF mit dem Budget ein wenig knauserig. Augenrollen, muss man leider sagen. Boring ZDF, boring. Boring. Das wäre immer geil. ZDF präsentiert den Schokoladen-Gummibären-Riegel. Ich glaube, da wäre geil, was zu holen. Ja, absolut. Ich heute nicht, und das war 2017 oder 16 oder sowas, hatten wir die Idee schon. Also seit acht Jahren wurde es immer noch nicht angefasst. Was ist das eheste, wo so Gummibärchenartige Massen mit Schokolade verknüpft wurden? Vielleicht diese Bananen, diese Gelee-Bananen. was es mal gab von Haribo waren die, eine Kombination aus Smarties und Goldbeeren.
Das war so Goldbeeren in so einer Zucker-Smartie-Hülle. Die fand ich auch richtig gut, die hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Ah ja.
Gab es irgendwann nicht mehr tatsächlich.
In so einer hohen Box, so einer kleinen Ricola-Box.
Nee, wir meinen schon Schokolade um den Gummibären herum.
Ja, aber das gibt es tatsächlich nicht, das ist auch gar nicht so gern gesehen, muss man tatsächlich sagen.
Oder Gummibär mit einem, wo ein kleines Herz, dem kleines Herz und das Schokolade. Aber so ein anatomisch korrektes, wirklich mit Herzklappen. Ich rede nicht von diesem romantischen Herz. Nee, nee, nee. Das muss wirklich von Kardiologen auch noch abgesegnet werden, dass die Herzklappen richtig rum sind. Und für die Grösse eines solchen Bären kann man sich überlegen, wie gross wäre das Herz eines Goldbären. Genau, und dann, wenn man das Rauchbeiss hat, hat man diesen Schoko. Das hätte ja aber echt geil, einen Kern, einen Schokokern in einem Komite. Ja, warum denn beim Herzen aufhören? Warum nicht alle Organe, die ein Goldbär so hat? Skelett. Ja, das Fruchtfleisch ist ja wirklich Fleisch. So Körperwelten, die in jedem Teil werden. Ja, finde ich richtig gut. Jetzt macht ihr bei mir in Ehrenfeld Körperwelten auf, um die ihr kippt. Ach was. Ja, finde ich spannend. Und da hast du vor, mal vorbeizuschauen? Auf jeden Fall. Ich war tatsächlich einmal in Körperwelten, als es gesellschaftlicher Diskurs war. Mittlerweile, glaube ich, ist das ja akzeptiert. Völlig egal. Aber damals war das ja Riesenthema, darf man das, sich selbst
zur Schau stellen,
Leichenfledderei. Ich finde ja diesen Charakter,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie er
heisst, dieser Lederhut tragende
Nekromant.
Nein, der Typ,
der die Leiche
der die aufschneidet
von Körperwänden.
Gulf Westerhagen oder halt irgendwie sowas. Wie ist der noch? Ich kann jetzt nicht Gulf Westerhagen. Wieso Nekromant? Lederhut tragender Nekromant? So heißt übrigens die Folge, Lederhut tragender Nekromant. Ja, Günther von Hagens, Erfinder der Plastination und Schöpfer der Körperfet.
Ah, das ist nicht der Hut.
So, und der stand damals ja oft in den Medien. Von Hagens, Erfinder der Plastination und Schöpfer der Körperwelt. Ah, das ist nicht der Hut.
Und der stand damals ja oft in den Medien.
Es ist so geil, ich habe aus meiner Kindheit so ganz punktuelle Medienerinnerungen irgendwie einfach mal.
Und Körperwelten ist ganz präsent, dass das diskutiert wurde, wie das ist.
Bei mir auch die Diskussion.
Wie nicht.
Ja, und dann gibt es ja dieses berühmte Kunstwerk, wo wir zwei Sex haben auch, oder? Ja, aber die Frage ist, war das vorher ein Paar? Naja, aber wie soll das denn gehen? Ne, eben, genau. Also was wahrscheinlich, waren fremde Menschen, die man nach dem Tod zum Kuitus gezwungen hat. Ne, aber sorry, aber jetzt rein anatomisch, also allein die Erektion ist ja... Ne, ne, das war dann was anderes. Oder ist das ... Das war so eine Nervenbahn dargestellt. Es war nämlich nicht ... Aber andererseits, genau, habe ich auch gesagt, da meinte dann der Kumpel, der mir das erzählt hatte, ja, aber alles andere ist ja auch präpariert und so und würde ja nicht mehr so halten. Das heißt, es ist ja ausgestopft. Es ist ja auch eine Kunst, das so zu präparieren, dass es dann irgendwie der Arm winkt oder so. Der winkt ja nicht so, weil da eine Leichenscharre angetreten ist. Und da kannst du ja bei der Erektion auch sicherlich ein bisschen rumspielen. Solange du die Haut nimmst, wird das schon funktionieren. Die ist ja auch so dehnbar. I don't know shit.
Gehen wir da nicht zu weit, ist meine Frage. Wenn du sagst, ich bin Fan der Wissenschaft und der Anatomie, ich opfer mich, meine Leiche darf in Körperwelten und dann wirst du da irgendwie da, also gibt es dann Grenzen, was man machen darf, ist die spannende Diskussion, die damals geführt wurde und die ich neu entfachen möchte, bitte. Wir entfachen die, und deswegen hört ihr ja das Podcast-Ufo, weil wir entfachen die Diskussion, die bereits hinlängst diskutiert wurden. Wo jeder schon müde ist von dieser Diskussion, wird hier nochmal entfachen. Jetzt fangen sie wieder an mit Körperwelten, ey. Ja, ich finde das spannend, ich habe da richtig Bock drauf. Aber alle Bilder, die ich hier sehe, sind langweilig. Alle Bilder, die man Google, wenn man Körperwelten googelt, sind doch einfach so Plastikpräparate. Ich glaube, das ist so in Plastik eingegossen oder irgendwie sowas. Also das sind dann schon so Hautscheiben, das ist schon so Körpermottadella. Und dann fragst du mich, wie man eine Erektion darstellen kann? Ja, einfach in Plastik. Das ist ja wirklich lame. Ich dachte, das wäre so, ich dachte, du hast dann so Tanks, wo dann so eine Ethanolflüssigkeit drin ist und da drin sind so Tote zu sehen. Da würde ich an der Mittagspause immer jeden Tag hingehen und mir sagen, ah, gut. Jesus Christ. Stehst du da mit deinem Croissant, mit deinem Schinkencroissant? Jeden Tag. Ich muss mal rauskommen, einfach zum Schreiben.
Wann ist man in der Laune, so was anzuschauen? Das ist ja wirklich schon crazy, crazy. Ja, es gibt so manche Sachen, die man, glaube ich, nicht besucht, wenn man selber in der Stadt wohnt. So klassisch so irgendwie das Foltermuseum. Ich glaube, da geht, so in Wien oder so, ich glaube, da geht, wenn man da zu Besuch ist und man ist eh in dieser morbiden österreichischen peiniger Stimmung, dann kann man sagen, jetzt gehen wir ins Foltermuseum oder da gibt es auch ein Sexmuseum oder so. Signalwort. Aber wenn du da wohnst, da sagst du ja nicht, oh jetzt mal Samstag, jetzt mal schön irgendwie einen reinfoltern. Genau, Signalwort Wanderausstellung. Wanderausstellungen sind nämlich dieser Natur. Das sind wirklich die, wo man dann reingeht, einfach mal, weil die da ist, kurz. So kurz. Aber die kann nicht lange an einem Ort bleiben, dann wäre die leer. Nee, die muss reisen, die muss weiter. Die Welt ist der Horizont. Du bist auch nicht als Vermieter, willst du ja nicht die ganze Zeit Körperwelten bei dir drin haben, weißt du, was ich meine? Absolut, und ich stelle mir immer nur vor, die müssen ja irgendwie transportiert werden. Und dann werden die ja alle verpackt in so einen Lkw. Und es gibt ja eine, wenn auch kleine Chance, dass genau dieser Lkw einen Unfall baut. und ich stelle mir vor, wie so ein Opper in so einem Ford-Fokus, er hat so einen leichten, leichten Auffahrunfall mit diesem Körperwelten-Lkw.
Und da passiert nicht viel, außer dass hinten dann diese Klappe, gab es einen Verschlussfehler, aufgeht und plötzlich liegen überall Leichen über seinem Auto.
Der Opa hatte den Schrecken seines Lebens, sexhabende Leichen auf der kühler Haube und der opa einfach was habe ich getan wo bin ich hier reingefahren der opa denkt oh nein ich habe hier bin ich in die früsteherzumme reingefahren oh mein gott korporierende menschen auf meiner motorhaube dabei hat er nur einen leichten leichten aufbau unter den körperwelten lkw gehabt. Wo ist die Haut komplett entfernt? Entfernt. Furchtbar, furchtbar. Aber muss es ja geben. Also klar, Autounfälle sind keine schöne Sache, aber es muss ja auch einfach alberne Autounfälle geben. Ich denke mir immer die Musik. Welche Musik läuft. Welche Musik läuft natürlich und was wird transportiert? Es gibt ja so ein Video von so einem auch leichten Autounfall, wo dann einer dem anderen hinten reinfährt und dann geht der Kofferraum aus und dann fliegen so Luftballons hoch. Ja, so als wäre das das Ziel gewesen. Als wäre das das Ende des Levels oder so. Als wäre das das Ziel. So, der hat halt Heliumluftballons transportiert im Kofferraum und dann geht der auf und die fliegen hoch. und wenn das nicht so richtig steu doch mal, fuck, fuck man und wenn der ist fliegen diese bunten Luftballons in die Luft und dann sieht er, dass die wegfliegen und er wird noch wütender, meine Luftballons! Meine Frage ist, waren die Heliumluftballons ursächlich für den Unfall? Das kann sein, also entweder Stichwort Sichtversprechung oder Signalwort Auftrieb oder darin, dass sie das Auto so leicht gemacht haben, dass die Haftung, die Reibung, die Traktion wird gering, die Reifentraktion gering. Signalwort Reifentraktion. Das kann sein, ja. Das musst du dann natürlich nachstellen, das muss nachgeprüft werden vom TÜV, aber kann sein, man weiss es ja tatsächlich oft nicht, was solche Auffahrunfälle verursacht. Das ist, glaube ich, der zusammenfassende Satz dieser Folge, am Ende weiss man es dann nicht. Leider nicht, das wird ja teilweise Jahrzehnte später noch untersucht, wie genau zur Seite geschoben, weggewunken, wie genau das passiert. Weil es so unspannend dann im Kern dann doch auch so uninteressant ist. Aber man muss sagen, es sind ja immer noch hunderttausende Auffahranfälle in Deutschland nicht gelöst und ignoriert. Genau, also fahrt nicht auf, kommt gut durch die Woche, ihr müsst aufpassen. Fahrt im Strassenverkehr nicht zu nah auf. Deswegen haben wir uns ja für den Senkrechtstarter entschieden, damit es keine Auffauunfälle gibt. Es sei denn, einmal, einmal, glaube ich, sind wir in so einen Heißluftballon geflogen. Einmal sind wir, wir starten ja immer kerzengerade und du hast ja, du willst ja das Verdeck immer nicht aufmachen, weil du sagst, dann kommen die Mücken rein, Verdeck ist zu, deswegen sehen wir nach oben nichts. Das heisst, wir müssen ein bisschen auf gut Glück senkrecht nach oben starten und einmal haben wir einen Heissluftballon umlaut.
Ja, von daher Hannelore und Günther ruten weiterhin in Frieden.
Das Letzte, was wir von euch gehört haben, ist, dass sie Ja gesagt hat und dann nur noch Hilfe, Hilfe, ich falle.
Und diese Nachricht hat keiner bekommen, weil die Nichte im Flugmodus war.
Deswegen lasst euch das in Leere sein und schaut, wohin ihr fliegt, fahrt, geht.
Au revoir, salut und tschüss.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, wenn es mehr heisst, wir landen.
Tschüss und Bis zum nächsten Mal. Wir heben ab. Wenn es heisst, wir landen. Tschüss und auf Wiedersehen.
Das Ganze war eine Produktion der Worst Bird Gesellschaft.